it seems these days that almost anything
can become the topic of conspiracy
theories and that includes one of
America's major airports opened in 1995
Denver International has long been the
subject of wildest speculation well when
the airport began a major renovation
project they decided it was a chance to
play along Barry Petersen has that story
[Music]
flying saucers have invaded our planet
Washington London Paris
if the saucers ever do carry may we
suggest another landing zone
Denver's Airport
where some say the welcome signs are
already up for gargoyles and are they
really making a new home for the lizard
people as workers remodel the main
terminal and why is this guy well this
thing shushing us it's all out of focus
and weird
well one may say these are the type of
visitors that we have underground in our
facility
Stacey Stegman is the Airport
spokesperson what's really going on
what's really going on is we are
revitalizing our terminal improving
security creating additional capacity so
that we can serve our passengers into
the future okay that's boring this is a
lot more fun just for the record exactly
they even post on social media when
aliens roamed the Airport since it
opened in 1995 America's fifth busiest
airport has swirled with conspiracy
theories how the runways make a swastika
how the blue mustang statue earned the
nickname blue suffer after it fell over
and killed the artist and then the
murals some show peaceful times some
show apocalypse if art is in the eye of
the beholder conspiracy an investigative
journalist Jay Widener beholds doom city
underwater or flaming forest with scary
stuff it's telling people in the know
what this Airport is all about this
theory says baggage handlers share
basement space with a secret underground
railroad two bunkers and the Rocky
Mountains where top government officials
will survive nuclear war I heard that
it's maglev the whole thing's magnetic
levitation and as the airport has some
chuckles with conspiracy there is The
Cat in the Hat for thing I'm sorry but
this is a cat with a ten hat like is
that the imagery that Denver wants to
project zombie cat layers would you
really believe this well what people do
do you I'm not gonna comment on that so
the next time an extraterrestrial needs
a lift
cause we now know the perfect Airport to
jump that flight for CBS this morning
Saturday Barry Petersen Denver
I love that the Denver Airport has a
sense of humor about itself they
certainly do can't get that image now
the cat out